Steve Kaplan: To go back to Connections, in
SPY Movie we have Melissa McCarthy meeting
all sorts of people that are going to come
to help her.
She meets Aldo who is this seemingly Italian
spy who is working for the CIA but who is
always on the make and seemingly is always
trying to stick his tongue down Melissa McCarthy’s
throat.
Her friend Nancy, who is there helping her
from the basement in Langley (Virginia - CIA
headquarters) shows up in Rome and is going
to help her deal with all her missions as
she’s trying to retrieve the nuclear bomb.
Even Rayna who is seemingly her nemesis (played
brilliantly by Rose Byrne) turns out (in the
end) in fact be another ally.
So in Connections is the part of the movie
in which your protagonist not only is moving
outside their comfort zone, becoming a more
actualized, more complete person.
But they are able to reach out and create
new relationships on a new basis.
One of the things that I do want to talk about
in terms of the Normal World, one of the things
I didn’t mention yet is that in the Normal
World your protagonist has flawed or absent
relationships.
Bill Murray (GROUNDHOG DAY) doesn’t have
a girlfriend, he doesn’t really respect
women.
Ben Stiller in TROPIC THUNDER, his only relationship
is his agent and even that is just kind of
somebody to get him a tebow to be sent to
this jungle where he’s shooting this movie.
And of course, Melissa McCarthy (SPY) has
no relationships.
She pines for Jude Law and we can see from
an earlier scene where Jude Law takes her
out to dinner to thank her for being such
a good helper back in the CIA basement.
That’s where he kind of gives her this terrible
crazy cupcake piece of jewelry, because we
can see that he doesn’t really see her as
an equal.
So in the Connections part of the Comic Hero’s
Journey, because your character is transforming,
your character is growing, and again, without
them knowing it, we the audience can see it,
but they’re still not aware of it.
That is when these unexpected allies and also
unexpected enemies can come out.
That’s the part of the movie where Melissa
McCarthy realizes that Karen Walker, whom
she idolized, who was a star femme fatale
spy at the CIA, was really a double agent.
QUESTION FOR THE VIEWERS: Think of any comedy
movie, does the main character have any flawed
or absent relationships in the beginning?